The Joe Rogan Experience have you ever
seen like the numbers of people that are
working in chocolate
that are working in like horrible
conditions have you ever heard of this
Jamie find out about chocolate
someone was telling me the chocolate in
many ways I have to be careful about
this because I'm not sure if they're
right let's look up what it is but they
were connecting we were talking about
Cobalt mines
and they said have you ever looked into
chocolate and chocolate production
it's like
here it is
Mars Wrigley Factory fined after two
workers fall into chocolate vat well
that's not it I think they're talking
about uh cacao farming and that uh he
was I think he was insinuating that they
used slave labor at some of those places
oh yeah I'm sure I mean that's the
um God who was I talking to man God damn
it I have such a
soggy brain oh man they were talking
about how they child labor and slavery
in the chocolate industry this is it
Jesus Christ okay can you make that
larger for my Shady eyes
um chocolate is the product of the cacao
bean which grows primarily in the
tropical climates of Western Africa Asia
and Latin America the cacao bean is more
commonly referred to as cocoa so that is
the term that will be used throughout
this article western African countries
mostly Ghana and the Ivory Coast Supply
about 70 percent of the world's cocoa
look is it coca or cocoa how do you say
that no because I always say cocoa like
I don't know cacao cacao shitty
c-o-c-o-a but it's not cacao because the
cacao bean and then it's cocoa
the cocoa they grow uh sorry everybody
chocolate they grow and harvest is sold
to a majority of chocolate companies
including the largest in the world in
the past few decades a handful of
organizations and journalists have
exposed the widespread use of child
labor and in some cases slavery on Coca
farms in Western Africa child labor has
been found on Cocoa farms in Cameroon
Guinea Nigeria Sierra Leone
although since most of Western Africa's
coca-grown in Ghana and the Ivory Coast
the majority of child labor cases have
been documented in those two countries
[__] yeah you just you don't like the it
says Brazil too scroll up a little bit
you just don't think that do you no when
you're eating a KitKat in recent years
evidence has also surfaced that both
child labor and slavery on Cocoa farms
in Brazil coca workers there face many
of the same abuses as those on Coca
farms in Western Africa
[__]
and then Latin America too they're
saying
one dollar per day Jesus Christ one
dollar per day a kitkats four days work
isn't it crazy that chocolate is like
love and there's chocolate there's like
chocolate stores come in and buy
chocolate chocolate like if you walk by
a chocolate store there's you never say
oh child labor oh yeah a lot of kids
died for that [__] chocolate you're
giving for your a lot of little tiny
unformed bodies are being forced to dig
holes in the ground dig holes just
getting [__] getting malaria yeah you
you the the the
this is the
this oh I'm sorry whoever told me this
they were uh they went on a tour of the
coliseums in Italy and uh the person
giving the guy giving the tour was
talking about how you know the horrible
[__] the Romans used to do in the
coliseums like that like that it was
just pure brutality and the guide says
but it's just as brutal now but in a
different way and that's what she's
talking about it's like yeah we don't
have coliseums where we're like throwing
Christians to lions and laughing as they
get eaten by a lion but we you know most
things that you are indulging in is just
something fun a little bit of chocolate
you're you know your [__] iPhones the
Cobalt the whatever it is it's just
soaked in the in misery and violence and
suffering like the whole thing still is
interconnected interconnected yeah I
mean now that being said what are you
supposed to do about that are you gonna
stop eating chocolate calculator using
your phone that's what's crazy it's like
they've got us addicted particularly
well chocolate would be an easier one
but phones
we we are all willingly addicted to
these things we're all checking our
email yeah and posting stuff and you
know using it for our podcasts and yeah
you're using it it's a device it's
important you have to have it you have
to have it but it's all connected right
to Cobalt mining which is one of the
most horrific things that's happening
right now on planet Earth and if people
in the cities in America were forced to
live like that everyone would be up in
arms but yet people were tweeting about
letting people through the Border crisis
we have this border problem we need to
help these people they're tweeting it on
a phone made by slaves yeah which is the
wildest thing ever it's very odd it's
very uh rarely discussed it's called so
it's ignorance and like this this is in
Buddhism there's three like the root of
suffering one of them is ignorance and
ignorance is not like you're ignorant
you're a dumbass it's like you're
actively ignoring [__] like you know
this this is one of the nightmare weed
situations is when you've been ignoring
some [__] in your life and even though
you know it's there you've just been
ignoring it and then you get high and
it's like you can't I'm not gonna let
you ignore this for a little bit Yeah
and then you have the bad weed trip
because now suddenly you're like looking
at a relationship that is shitty in your
life that needs to improve or you're
like you're looking at like how you
don't exercise or whatever the thing is
yeah so you've been actively ignoring
that and thinking that is going to make
the situation better even though when
you're actively ignoring something you
feel it yeah you might not it might not
might not be the top of mind but you're
like feeling it and it's heavy it's a
it's a heavy thing when you're
procrastinating that's active ignorance
so I think collectively that's what
we're doing here is this an active
ignorance of the reality that these
things don't pop out of thin air yeah if
for if we're gonna have this level of
luxury some people are gonna have to
suffer for it but that's not necessary
really true they don't have to they just
are
it's not like you couldn't figure out a
way where the company profits slightly
less the people live far better and
phones cost
reasonably close to what they cost to
now you you the problem those like you
look at a company like apple they're
just the amount of money that they've
generated from devices and what
percentage of it is phones What
percentages of what percentage of of
what they sell involves Cobalt I mean
most of their lithium-ion battery
products the Cobalt is like some sort of
a stabilizer or something no idea
Siddharth Cara who wrote that book on
Cobalt who came on the podcast and had
this it was one of the most heavy
podcasts I've ever done because you just
like you're sitting here
and he's exposing how these people are
living how these 19 year old mothers
have babies on their backs and they're
digging into these Hills to get cobalt
and the dust is coming up and it's
horrific horrific for them terrible
Health consequences they're being
poisoned and they're making no money and
they have no electricity yeah and don't
forget that those Cobalt mines are not
even owned by Africans they're usually
owned by like Chinese Chinese yeah and
if you just imagined that instead those
people lived in an economic economically
thriving town like Detroit was when they
were putting together automobiles like
Detroit at one point in time was one of
the richest country or richest cities in
the country Detroit was a huge Hub there
was beautiful cars everywhere America
was making these cars and they were
selling like crazy the industry was
booming and then they pulled it all out
yeah and then the City imploded like if
you went to Detroit during when did
Detroit fall apart when did when did the
auto manufacturers pull a giant chunk of
their their production out of Detroit
what year was that because it's a very
Stark Cliff economically it's like Roger
and me when when when he made that
documentary
oh yeah 1960s
when a building boom pushed people to
the suburbs a population plummeted to
700 000 with the highest unemployment
rate more than 16 percent in any major
American city
yeah
so it started with the building boom
pushed back people into the suburbs but
I think the big one was the Automall so
what is Detroit's downfall yeah it's the
heavily automobile Centric industrial
landscape of Detroit established in the
first half of the 20th century led to
Rapid declines in population and
economic output after Automotive
decentralization I think that that means
that they took their factories to other
countries with fewer regulations exactly
what they did
it's exactly what they did and it makes
you think like man what did you do what
did you do for like how much more profit
I'm sure it's a lot of money a lot but
what did you do